Speaking of women in sports,
Thursday is baseball's Opening Day,
and boy, have we got the perfect guest here to celebrate,
Tiki!
(Tiki chuckles)
She is a former pro baseball player,
who played in the All-American Girls Baseball League,
the real life league that inspired the phenomenal film,
"A League of Their Own."
Please welcome an ace pitcher from Southern California,
Maybelle Blair!
(audience applaud)
(whooping)
How are you?
Hey Maybelle, how are you?
Oh God, the old girl couldn't be better, Tiki.
(chuckles) Oh, I love it, I love it!
All right, Maybelle, tomorrow is opening day,
who are you going to be watching?
Oh my God!
Every ball game I can watch,
with my Dodgers, and my Angels, my Red Sox,
and now with the Florida Marlins (indistinct),
but, it can mean-
Yes
Be the first woman general manager, can you believe that?
That shows the advancement
of women in professional sports.
We're seeing professional football teams
have women coaches, right?
Yep!
So we know that it's changing slowly but surely.
It started because of you,
Maybelle!
That's right!
(audience cheering)
Yeah, can you believe that?
This old 94-year-old girl helped a little bit,
not much.
(Tiki chuckles)
But, oh my God!
I'm so excited with what's happening.
Maybelle, I have a question for you, which is,
you're young, it's in the 1940s,
obviously there's a very different time for women.
What is a good tip for young people today
to hook into their passion?
The main thing today
is to get out there and do your damnedest,
because it is going to happen Drew.
We are going to open it up, we're going to do our...
We're going to get a new league,
in fact, we're working on it now.
We're trying to get our own museum going,
and it's happening, and if you love it follow it.
'Cause look at Tiki, he's sitting there,
he probably didn't think
he was gonna play professional football, but he did,
and look what he did, and us girls can do the same thing.
(applause)
And we're so excited to-
(indistinct chatter)
(audience claps)
That is so true Maybelle.
I have four daughters,
I don't want them to be limited by anything, so absolutely!
You're an inspiration Maybelle,
thank you so much for being you.
I mean, seriously, you started something profound,
and we're still feeling it.
Yeah, absolutely!
Well, thank God!
I am so thrilled about it, it has opened up college sports
and everything,
now in the WNBA,
and I'm so proud of those girls, they're doing their thing,
and girls are getting scholarships,
and baseball is finally opening their eyes
that we can play baseball.
So, let us have an opportunity to play,
let these girls have that, that's what I'm working for
while I'm on this side of the grass.
(chuckles)
Well, and all the data
in the world says that young girls
who get involved in sports,
just have a better shot at like, quality focus,
lovely friendships.
It's just-
Educational opportunities,
scholarships,
all those things
Yes!
You're absolutely right, Drew.
Thank you Maybelle for showing, especially in the 1940s,
what was possible.
And please go to our show website,
and find out how you can support women in baseball,
and Maybelle's Museum.
(audience cheering)
Oh my gosh, yeah!
And I (indistinct)
(applause)
And you were a Peoria Redwing, in fact, Maybelle,
we have a clock here dedicated to Peoria, Illinois,
and our affiliate station, WMBD.
Oh, how wonderful!
Well-
You can't beat that.
You can't!
And you can't beat you Maybelle,
thank you so much for coming on the show today.
(soft synth music)